imagine this scenario in 2024 there are
seven candidates for president a
Democrat a Republican and the nominees
of fringe parties favoring right to life
choice gun control and the green New
Beetle and a billionaire who says he's a
socialist an election day the
billionaire gets only 23% of the vote
but becomes president impossible you say
because no one can win 270 electoral
votes with only 23% of the popular vote
but under the National popular vote
compact an agreement among many states
that their electoral votes will go to
the candidate who has the most popular
votes it can happen
states with 189 electoral votes have
approved the plan and it goes into
effect when states with 270 electoral
votes have joined so a fringe candidate
who gets a small fraction of the total
vote but still the highest percentage of
the group will get all 270 electoral
votes of the participating states and
will become president do you think the
winner of the popular vote should become
president even though he or she only has
a small minority of the popular vote let
us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI